okay so here we are another
episode of eating your feed the show
where we make food from viral videos is
challenged by the man behind the camera
adam bianchi and today we're making
giant cinnamon rolls we have our good
friend and colleague tasty producer ray
mcclenny to help us when we're surely
going to need help are you a very good
baker
oh no it's a place called lulu's bakery
cafe they make a three pound cinnamon
roll i don't know family of its pounds
how many cats do you measure things by
cat in japan
it's pretty satisfying watching a giant
sheet of dough get folded it looks like
a blanket now we got this tasty video
where some guy tried to recreate it so
i'm thinking about maybe doubling or
even tripling this recipe to get like a
really satisfying big sheet of dough
we're gonna have to do so much math this
is the now the math show are you excited
look somebody else left their shopping
list oh cute
three cups of powdered sugar
i don't know these came like that yeah
we did it
right in the kisser chocolate milk we
need a snack to get us going
so here we've got all of our ingredients
get some chocolate milk you like
chocolate milk i'm lactose intolerant
will you have a little bit sure
let's do this we have our butter milk
sugar 10 pounds of flour that's a cat's
worth of flour
first thing we're going to do is put
together the dough add
warm milk to a large bowl we begin six
cups of milk
oh we need to measure one and a half
cups of melted butter what
i think it's great that butter comes and
sticks i'm gonna measure the sugar so
the sugar is the yeast's food
that's a lot of sugar it's a giant
cinnamon roll
oh god got our packs of yeast
i'm gonna get a knife to level off the
uh
okay
got a knife
level that
oh one two ish three
four five
six
what is that six
that's seven right
[Music]
well that's 12.
it was 12.
we've got our warm
to the touch milk
melted butter goes in there
next they think the sugar
all right yeast is going in so we're
letting the yeast become
activated in this warm
sugary pool so that it can start eating
sugar and farting which creates the gas
that makes bread rise 12 cups of flour
[Music]
now we're making dough look at that it's
already dough-like
is that a blanket yeah
leave it in a warm place this place is
pretty warm right setting a timer for
one hour cool
time to add flour baking powder
and salt oh i don't have salt
what salts do i want to use if i'm
baking something you think kosher is
fine
i've got the salt
kind of feels like like a really
high-tech foam for like a space-age
pillow so we're adding six teaspoons of
salt right now that feels like more than
six yeah i did twelve oh it's twelve yes
okay how much baking powder three
teaspoons so six of these
more flour two and one quarter
can you get all the filling ready
yeah so we'll just
divide and conquer actually fun thing i
just learned from a history podcast
divide and conquer comes from roman
times and it means to divide the people
that you're conquering so that they're
weaker not you split yourself and
conquer them
pull it together now oh that's a weird
texture all right i'm just going to dump
it out here we are so we just knead it
together now yeah
oh
really poke it yeah it's bouncing back
so it's good
[Music]
oh this doesn't feel right i feel like
it's still the same shape
let me just turn this into a pizza and
also it's not gonna be giant
just imagine you
finish rolling it up it's more like
you're making a bunch of small cinnamon
roll size so what do we do to make this
giant maybe if we just it's not going to
make six giant cinnamon rolls right
so we should try to make two
as big as possible and just make this a
longer fatter rectangle that we'll get
two out of
yeah we're doing the cinnamon part we're
gonna mix all of our cinnamon and sugar
in here
it's like a world war one helmet three
quarters of a cup of sugar
oh
oh it's so cinnamony
oh cinnamon toast crunch
that's a very satisfying color okay so
we're gonna dump this warm butter onto
the dough first before putting the
cinnamon mixture on
that feels good
i'm just gonna do a quick
and then you like massage it in and make
those clumps
oh it feels so
unusual
okay let's roll this bad boy up
you hold it together i'm gonna go get
the knife and cut it okay get this ready
so i'm gonna go cut side up adam
i gotta butter that hold it
oh sorry
so now we let it rest for another half
an hour hopefully they'll still be
cinnamon roll shaped by the end of that
and then they go in the oven
for a little over an hour we left the
oven preheating now we're going to
transfer the cinnamon rolls into this
one with more enforceables don't forget
butter the pan does need more butter
oh it's
tilting
[Music]
yeah there you go buddies
big boys it looks a little scary but
looks
good
[Music]
oh it's not it's i think we need one
more then do half of it do you want a
long how to wrap properly
yeah
yeah
oh
wow
it's so elegant
true for this in a warm place or just is
this i think just
leave others i don't want them to get
very much bigger
i think they've gotten too giant they've
gotten less circular and more like
skinny blob
all right let's pop these in the oven we
definitely just picked that whole thing
up
oh my god they're gigantic
oh
[Music]
oh my god yeah it's definitely raw at
the bottom
so they feel pretty hard on top well
keep it together so i don't want it to
get any darker on top so i'm just gonna
cover it with some foil
okay
another 30 minutes to go now we'll
prepare the frosting we're gonna go with
the cream cheese frosting that's in the
tasty video four ounces cream cheese
times three two tablespoons butter
melted times three powdered sugar
teaspoon vanilla extract six tablespoons
of this
[Music]
should have cubed it
[Music]
i mean it's good it's just chunky i'm
gonna get an electric mixer
[Music]
we can't fix this
ah we didn't soften our cream cheese and
now our frosting is chunky
the cheese flavor
is very prevalent delete this part of
the video i can't put it at on my
beautiful perfect cinnamon roll so the
cream cheese didn't soften it now we're
trying again so we're gonna dial back
the cream cheese use a little bit more
sugar
that's gonna be that
okay timer's up so we're gonna split
duties
oh jesus
we accidentally touched it too much
after we let it rest before it went in
the oven so they deflate it a bit we're
not sure if these are actually done yeah
it's done okay i feel like more than
oh so we overdid it yeah cool well how
should we get it out
oh
i think just flip it upside down yeah oh
my god it's so heavy got it we got it we
got it
wow
look at that
oh i smooshed it but whatever
this is basting
that's what they do in the texas video
they based it with butter yeah there you
go which one do you think looks better i
think this one okay yeah
oh
that's a giant cinnamon roll
[Music]
oh see
it looks more like a loaf of something
than a roll of any kind really with any
cinnamon roll you want to be able to
tear into it oh it's so ugh it's so hot
inside and get that tear away
delicious flakiness oh just the steam
this is not bad the texture isn't quite
right but it does taste like a cinnabon
you want to try something
yeah you look like a chicken wings
[Music]
yeah
tastes good
no
i think we went too big i think probably
the cafe in texas did this same thing
where they made it too big
yeah i don't know why we thought we
could beat them at their own game
yeah
that's a cinnamon roll oh i'm starting
to not feel good too much sugar i think
yeah i just had one bite but like my
heart is beating so fast it might just
be the excitement of giant food so
there's a guy downstairs named scott he
is obsessed with cinnamon rolls he's
actually the guy who made the giant
cinnamon roll tasty video so we're gonna
gift him
our second giant cinnamon roll because
what could make a guy happier than a
pretty bad giant version of his favorite
dessert
all right we made a giant cinnamon roll
scott we uh referenced your video so i'd
like you to try a little bit and tell me
what you think we actually tripled your
recipe this weighed to 5.5 pounds that's
disgusting
they're pretty good
i mean a giant cinnamon roll makes
pretty much anybody's day mission
accomplished you guys oh yes